it seems like the Khan Academy is more
popular than expected with the press in
the new year and I still have that
request out there for people living in
New Delhi New Delhi new delhi bangkok
bangkok dubai dubai and what was the
other place or Hong Kong who would be
willing to talk to an international
press organization they're doing a piece
on the kind of heavy that's still out
there but I've actually been contacted
by another press organization a
different one this is actually for a
national show in the US but they are
interested in doing a skype interview
you don't have to live in one of these
four cities are interested in doing a
skype interview with people literally
living anywhere and the only requirement
is literally that you have a webcam that
you have skype they're going to be over
at my house tomorrow that's january
january fifth 2010 they're going to be
over at my place from 12pm to 1pm
Pacific Standard Time Pacific Standard
Time so if you are free at this time and
you do have skype and you like the Khan
Academy and you want to do a skype
interview with them let me know send me
an email at salad Khan Academy cell at
Khan Academy khanacademy.org org either
if this applies to you or that applies
to you i want you neither case you to
contact me i can't guarantee you
anything one way or the other but we'll
try to skype you around these hours if
they are interested in talking to and
when you email me let me know a little
bit about yourself context that you use
the Khan Academy and what not and this
organization has also said even if we
can't find enough people at this time
frame they might be interested in doing
some interviews with you once they're
not at my house anymore so even if even
if you can't necessarily be free from
12pm to 1 p.m. pacific standard time I
still popped me an email if you're
interested in talking to them and we
might be able to set something else up
as long as it's kind of a reasonable
time frame for someone in the west coast
of the United States someone out here in
San Francisco to set up a skype session
so let me know what other times you
might be free to actually do a session
so just want to
clear these actually two separate news
organizations or after a long time of
relatively being a enough known entity
it seems like people are starting to get
interested in the Khan Academy which is
exciting but the first request was for
people living particularly in these
three cities to actually want to go
visit you in your house and see how you
use Khan Academy but there's a
completely separate requests for people
who have skype access there's another
national us news organization that would
like to conduct Skype interviews with
you so either way email me and let me
know in what context you use the site